but he set a high bar with the idea of
comparing this to kick a pan and I'm not
going to dare to do that this is a fun
kind of talk for me to give because once
in a while in your career you get to
give a new talk it's on a completely new
subject which means you don't know as
much about it and it's at the beginning
of something and that's always very very
exciting for me so I hope that you
enjoyed as much as I do we're going to
talk about a new project that we're
doing in the create lab the create lab
is a community and Technology
empowerment and how we can use
technology to change communities not by
us changing from the outside but by
having the communities change themselves
and so in talk it's about electric
vehicles and the role that they can have
and how we can view the future of
electric vehicles and imagine it with
the community centric point of view but
I've actually cared about electric cars
longer than I've cared about robotics or
artificial intelligence I started
working at electric cars in 1988 20
years ago so it's much older for me than
my interest in the things that I've been
doing more recently and so I thought
maybe the personal story is a good one
to start with these are the only two
electric vehicles I've ever driven in my
life until today when i drove a third
electric vehicle courtesy of the create
lab so I wanted to tell you a little bit
about them and explain why this matters
the one on the left is called the
Stanford Sun surfer and when i was a
freshman at Stanford University we
founded the project of the Stanford
solar race car project and a group of
about seven of us and then a lot of
volunteers on top of that designed and
built a car from the ground up that was
all electric and all solar power so it
was completely self-contained powered
car we built this for a GM sunrace
challenge that was to drive from Florida
to Detroit without any wall charging
right without any any carbon footprint
lyst so ever and that was a fun project
it was of course heady times we spent
two years on that project almost failing
all the classes and instead working on
the project and we learned a lot there's
three major lessons that are took away
from that that I think are very relevant
to what was happening now one is about
simplicity you know a bunch of students
built that car with one fantastic
faculty advisor named Robert kincheloe
who is an electrical engineering back
then it's Stanford I was amazing guy and
what's interesting about that is that a
bunch of students could put a car
together and the reason we could do such
a thing from the ground
up was because an electric car is so
simple compared to the gasoline cars
that we face today and that simplicity
made it possible for us to create
something out of nothing in a way that I
don't think it would have been possible
for a bunch of non mechanical folks like
we were the second thing I learned has
to do with the feeling that you get
driving this thing I was one of the race
car drivers so I got to drive this thing
from Florida to Michigan but being on
the road being in the Sun SPOT seeing
some shade up ahead so slowing down so
you charge the batteries on the Sun
looking at your little ammeter and
realizing you're not burning any power
you're traveling up miles and you're not
using anything your solar panels are
creating all the energy you are using
that feeling really inspired me and it
really inspired me to think about the
future of technology and transportation
and the third thing that's interesting
about that car I don't think people
recognize very much that car had
regenerative braking because that made a
lot of sense we have a really nice
powerful unique mobility motor you
certainly want to slow down with the
motor so as I'm driving that car sitting
in a seat from a recumbent bicycle that
was the seat that we had for it you had
your foot on the accelerator and then
your head your hand on the regenerative
braking which is a linear pot you'd pull
back on this lever to break and you were
constantly in this mode of dithering
with the accelerator regenerative
braking looking at the ammeter and
looking at the amp power meter playing
with all of these maximizing your
efficiency capturing back as much energy
as you possibly could on that downhill
thinking about where the clouds are
what's shaded what's sunny slowing down
speeding up so you became this
incredible control algorithm optimizing
the whole system with your hands and
your legs kind of like flying a
helicopter that feeling of optimizing
and that feeling of acts of control
didn't leave me and the idea that when
you drive an electric car you can do
that and by doing that you're
manipulating controls that make the car
far more efficient than anything else on
the road so those are the three lessons
that I got from that car the car on the
right is a rav4 EV it mine was made in
2001 and it's been my primary commute
vehicle since then so let me say this
again since 2001 I've been driving an
electric car more than any other car in
fact more than all other cards combined
every day that I Drive and it's an
electric okay now there's three lessons
that I take away from that first of all
I cannot even count on two hands it
would
many hands the number of times that my
wife and I are sitting in that car
driving at 70 75 miles an hour on the
road to say the airport or to ligonier
somewhere this 50 miles away going 75
listening to the radio and national
public radio no less here thing about a
story on NPR where the expert is
explaining and the journalist is
explaining that electric cars are not
reliable they really don't have range
they can't go at highway speeds and
therefore they're really not practical
yet and the number of times since 2001
that I've been sitting in this car
driving listening to that and laughing
about it it's become kind of a laugh at
first I sent letters to them and then I
kind of gave up after a while so the gap
between the reality of what the electric
car is to me in my heart because of how
I use one and the promise or lack of
promise that I here in the world of
journalism and often science is always
been impressing to me the second thing
that I gained from that car is people's
interests since 2001 to this day with no
decrease in efficacy when I drive this
car everybody stops you and ask you
about it you go to giant eagle the
supermarket and stop people come to my
car and asked me about it and they want
to know everything about it they want to
know how it runs they wonder how you
plug it in they want to know how many
cents per mile it is to drive it and you
soon have all this data on your lips
because they care I went to a parking
garage in downtown Pittsburgh went to
the symphony for a children's symphony
performance went back out to the parking
lot attendant he was a very old
gentleman he'd been in World War two
okay he couldn't stop asking questions
about this car what kind of batteries do
you have in it I was driving tanks and
World War two and it was very
interesting sir because our tanks had
really bad lit acid batteries and he
wouldn't start in the mornings after a
cold cold night but the Germans had
these really nice tanks at Nick nickel
batteries and they started no problem
what do you think of that can I get one
of these cars and these continued to
this day and it's a cut of society that
cuts across socio-economic boundaries
when we're doing educational programs in
braddock I get just as many questions as
shadyside and so it's really interesting
the level of public interest and
engagement with the idea of electric
cars the third thing that car since 2001
has been to a mechanic's shop precisely
zero times ever okay
there is no scheduled maintenance
there's no regular check-ups there's an
oil to change the only things I've ever
done to the car is that replaced the
four tires they wore out the brakes have
never worn out because guess what it's
got regenerative braking so most of the
time you're using the motor to slow down
so the brakes last a whole lot longer
and I can leave it at that but the
reliability of that car fundamentally
it's data point of one but it's a really
interesting teaching lesson in the
comics of electric cars and actually it
relates a little bit to the politics of
electric goes so that's the electric car
mentality that I come to this project
with and as we enter the foray of
electric cars you can ask where is the
state of the art what are people doing
in the world of electric vehicle
technology and there's one picture that
says it all the battery particularly
appropriate picture because this is the
e 95 battery that my car has the rav4 EV
I have 24 of those under the car 24 and
a half kilowatt hours of power so enough
power to run your house for several days
now it's a telling picture because this
is also the battery that we can no
longer buy its patent was bought up by a
gas company yes oh yes the battery is
this big and it's about a 1 kilowatt
hour battery so not too big in fact it
will show you afterwards in the garage
of that the underside of the car and you
can see the batteries so they still a
little plastic trays under there but
yeah there's a patent dispute with this
batter we can't even buy it today if a
battery goes bad on my car you have to
reconstruct some kind of 12 volt battery
you can't replace it with a existing set
new but the battery has really been at
the forefront of research for the
electric vehicle so companies and
researchers have really worked hard to
make the battery better and the fact
that my car just doesn't mean mean we
don't need to make the battery better of
course we do there's plenty of room for
improvement and that's being done and
time it again you'll hear about the
battery fundamentally though I want to
talk a little bit about energy store
about the architecture that you can use
to drive these cars and how we could
imagine change in architecture now if we
look at the cars that are going to come
out in the next three or so years what
is their architecture what do they like
and how does the battery relate to them
let's look at a few so this is one of my
favorites the Nissan Leaf it's hopefully
going to be out in two to three years
and when you buy a nissan leaf it's a
four-door proper car goes at highway
speeds and i think it goes about 80
miles on a charge what's interesting is
the battery is
n at the center of the conversation you
don't buy the battery you lease it and
why is that why would they set it up
that way because the batteries are
expensive because it's not well defined
how long they last and they really don't
know how to price it so the least model
makes a lot of sense for them another
car that tells the story about batteries
this is a tesla model s so when the
Model S comes out from Tesla will have a
large chat d5 it's expensive right i
think it's about sixty thousand dollars
at the latest estimate the real
interesting thing though is when you buy
the car you can actually add additional
monies in you can pay more than the car
costs to buy your future battery pack
for when the first battery pack goes bad
so another interesting financial model
to try and cover the issue of
uncertainty around how long the
batteries last will give you a discount
on the future cost of the battery if you
battery now essentially forward funding
our company and last but not least the
chevy volt which will be exciting to see
again a car that's got quite a lot of
range in this case we actually have a
John word generator to keep the battery
charged the story of these cars that I
find interesting and that we're going to
try and transition from for the purposes
of this talk these are proper top-down
engineering design challenges we're
designing a new car but what they're
trying to do is design a car that looks
and feels and operates 141 like a
gasoline car the problem they're trying
to solve as engineers is can we make an
electric vehicle that is essentially the
same as a gasoline vehicle it has the
same range fundamentally in the same top
speed that's the problem we're trying to
solve and there's a good reason for that
that's what the market is we know how
many cars people buy if we make a
replacement for that car this electric
but it still goes a couple hundred miles
like the Tesla Model S we hope people
will buy that car that's the direction
that they go the question that I want to
ask and the challenge that we're facing
with charge card is rather than thinking
about 14 1 replacements with cars can we
turn the problem upside down and think
about the commute what is the people
face and what are ways in which we can
optimize an electric car for the commute
to people face so that's what I want to
think but to have that discussion we
need to start by understanding the coop
so let's go to this place to start which
is the typical commute
so this is Department of Transportation
Statistics across the distance that
people commute one way and it's just a
histogram showing that in buckets hard
to read so I'll explain it to you but
here's 125 miles 6 to 10 miles 15 miles
20 miles 25 miles let's do a poll how
many people one-way commute let's do the
first two buckets 1 to 10 miles a day
yes everybody look around Wow less than
one mile okay wait I don't sorry so how
about 125 miles all right how about 6 to
10 miles we're actually a perfect
representative sample of this
transportation statistic that's kind of
cool the largest bucket was 125 and
basically everybody was here so that's
interesting if that's true right if
that's what the regular commute is then
trying to do a one-for-one replacement
to a gasoline car is not necessarily the
optimal thing to do after all we may
have interesting opportunities that our
eyes we may be able to exploit behavior
and interesting ways if instead of
thinking about that one for one
replacement we think about fitting what
people need in some interesting way so
that's where we start our conversation
nap together and you could the question
manufactures work on that do they try
and build low mileage vehicles
specifically for commuting and answers
of course they do that's what the
bicycle is and there's other devices for
that see T&T announce the e zone very
recently I think a week and a half ago
and that's very exciting because it's a
job creation effort for Pennsylvania
right we're going to have a 200 employee
plant manufacturing these here near
Pittsburgh and another one near
Philadelphia which is fantastic now this
car is range i believe is about 60 miles
80 miles so 80 miles of range and has
led acid batteries but you know what's
interesting morphologically this is
different from those cars right it looks
totally different it's small it's cute
it's a two-seater its top speed is 35
miles an hour so the fact that it goes
35 means there's a whole bunch of these
people that it doesn't actually work for
like me who go faster than 35 maybe I
could for squirrel hill to hear figure
out a way to go less than 35 so the look
is different the morphology is different
but if you look under the hood if you
look at how that electric car works this
car
and this car and this car are all the
same thing they're a battery and
electric motor and a controller and
that's it no interesting intelligence to
speak of so that's where I get excited
right all the solutions being proffered
today are largely the same and usually
evolution works well if you have some
dissimilarity to begin with so that we
can see what works and what doesn't so
I'm going to try and convince you of
that by thinking about that orbit mute
thinking about this short distance
travel and what it's like how does it
behave what's the shape of that travel
and I have a good place to start which
is this thicker doesn't run Prius so the
sticker on 2,000 PS actually tells a lot
of stories that are interesting so we
need to talk about this but the most
important story that it tells us has to
do with these two numbers CD miles per
gallon highway miles per gallon now
every gasoline car you've ever seen in a
showroom highway miles per gallon is a
lot higher than the city miles per
gallon right and the priest was a little
odd because the city miles per gallon
would be significantly higher than the
highway miles per gallon why would that
be how could you do better in the city
of the highway when all these gas cars
are doing far better on the highway than
in the city well there's a natural
reason right there's a natural reason
that says oh well air resistance of
course you're going really fast you're
going to do much worse you're pushing
all that air fine but that was happening
with gas cars to the real reason isn't
because this car is breaking new records
in the city it's not because this cars
particularly special in the city it's
because gas cars are so terrible in the
city it's because the gasoline car is
such an absurdly bad idea the city so
why would that be why would a gas card
get such poor miles per gallon the city
in the highway so much so that when you
look at the gap the difference between
that gas car which would typically be
what 30 let's say 32 in this case to 50
to 20 miles per gallon difference
between a gas car and electric car in
the city why the difference well the
reason is actually pretty clear it's
because in the city in that urban
commute setting you doing a whole lot of
starting and stopping right and what's
the gas car not good at well it's
burning guess what is idling but that's
not a huge amount of gas more
importantly you're running that engine
through a huge range of RPM speeding up
accelerate
and you're slowing down when you slow
down you push the brake you make heat
and you lose all the energy you had when
you speed up you shift through gears you
make that RPM wildly fluctuate up and
down going through all sorts of regimes
when the engine is inefficient and only
hitting the efficient regimes once in a
while so it's not a great car for that
but fundamentally what is it about the
city that makes this to case what are
the environmental factors that make a CD
interesting and inefficient and bad for
a gas car well there's a number of them
one is the fact that in the city you've
got stop signs and stop lights right the
driving rules inherent to the city make
it bad it means you're going to stop in
startled but another written traffic
traffic is in the cities and that
traffic means you're stopping and
starting even if you're on a stretch of
the road that has no stoplights right
another reason topography our cities
often have hills Pittsburgh is a really
good example but there's a whole lot of
other cities i can give you as examples
and those hills by nature will not only
mean that you slow down and speed up but
that you push on that accelerate you put
on that brake again because you've got
hills another reason driver habits the
city is where there are Starbucks's and
now i guess it's Dunkin Donuts rather
than starbucks and everybody stops at
Dunkin Donuts to get their coffee and
then speeds up again it goes so you've
got stopping and starting not just even
because of traffic that because of all
the habits that we have is people as
human beings this is interesting because
now what we're saying is governing the
inefficiency of the left side of that
sticker is a whole ecology of things
that govern our relationship in urban
driving I'm calling this the commute
ecology for the sake of this talk to
explain what it is but there's some
things about this that are important
takeaways one is that is an individual
community ecology right it depends on
where you live it depends on who you are
Eric's commedia ecology is different
from mine because he drives differently
because he drives a different kind of
pattern of map and because he drives a
different times of day and so the
congestion is different so suddenly the
influences the factors that influence
the sensitivity of how good or bad the
efficiency of a car is in the city or
actually factors at the individual level
it's not about the highway and thought
to be on the highway at all it's about
everything that governs the individual
person that's interesting because that
means we may be able to exploit some of
that in some in some ways that are cool
so where do we start well it would be
nice to undress
when I say speed up and slow down what
we mean and we can ask the question
where is that number come from where
does that 52 in the city come from how
do you test the car to get that number
because maybe that's a place where we
can look for answers so here's a graph
that I didn't make this is the
Department of Transportation urban
dynamometer driving schedule what that
means is that this is what you do over
time you speed up you go three miles an
hour you stop then you go to 60 miles an
hour and stop then you go up to 35 miles
an hour and stop this is essentially a
recipe for how to drive a car on a
dynamometer or on a racetrack and then
measure how much gas you use and figure
out its CD miles per gallon so the first
thing you should notice is wow that's
not flat at all right it's a whole lot
of starting and stopping which is
exactly what we expect now the next
question we can ask ourselves is okay
all these stop descends right these are
all deceleration that's right those are
all times when in the gas call your
matching on the brakes being pretty
horribly inefficient what would happen
in electric car during these times so
the first thing charge card did is just
put together a naive physics simulator
that simulates the physics of a car
assumes the way to of in this case the
Toyota Scion and then forward simulates
what happens to the energetics of that
electric car on this schedule so if you
drive that electric car like this what
does the motor see how many kilowatts in
how many kilowatts out and that's this
picture now that's kind of fun to see
this must be very when six miles an hour
see we're all the way down to 40
kilowatts on that particular car of
course it depends right the specifics
depend on everything from the weight of
the car type of motors you're using but
what's neat to see about this is first
of all that is incredibly noisy high
variability second of all that above the
line 0 there you see those Peaks those
are all places where we're slowing down
that's exciting those are all chances we
have to gain efficiency if you add it up
so to speak the total amount of
discharge the total amount of time your
battery spending pushing out energy it
adds up to 3.3 kilowatt hours of power
of energy sorry total amount of charge
is point 3 kilowatt hours now that's
kind of exciting that means not in
percent charge to discharge proportion
so already I'm kind of interested in
that right it's like wow okay so an
electric car is right away something
like nine percent more efficient maybe
because nine percent of the time it's
recovering the energy that the gasoline
car is for sure losing that's
interesting now the problem with this
whole thing is that the urban
dynamometer driving system is an idea
it's not a real thing it's a concept the
theory it's a recipe for how to give the
same city miles per gallon sticker to
all the cars in the world what we really
care about is our drive because remember
I tried to argue the community ecology
special how we drive this particular and
now the good news comes in play I can
donate my car to science if i take my
electric car and donate it to our
project and we hack it then we can
actually drive it for real and for the
particular community colleges we subject
it to we can get an idea of what the
true efficiencies look like so we did
this and we're lucky enough that there's
an HP engineer who had already hacked
the Rob for to collect voltage and
amperage data on a Palm Pilot so we just
have to make a second board that records
all those numbers in real time and time
stamps and all that good stuff and so
then we could take my commute and that's
the little bored we made that that thang
the create labs josh shapiro this is the
commute round trip from squirrel hill to
see i see here at Carnegie Mellon and
back to squirrel hill now the first
thing you'll notice is yes it is as it
looks and I'd have to scale it to make
it equivalent for you but it is a lot
more variable even than the urban
dynamometer driving schedule much more
and the other cool thing to notice is
this is the zero line and if you stand
back and squint you can probably tell
there's a whole lot more above the zero
even than in the urban dynamometer case
so we're on the same analysis on this
now remember this is real data now this
is not with a simulator a physic
simulator total discharge to come to
Carnegie Mellon and go back to squirrel
hill five kilowatt hours total charge
one and a half kilowatt hours twenty-six
percent charged recharge to charge ratio
now that's getting really exciting
that's a double digit number it's large
and it suggests satra mendes difference
in the overall efficiency of the gas car
versus the electric car for this
particular commute and i will show you
better that's not the best by any means
but this got us interested right it got
us interested in this idea
that high frequency that charging and
discharging over time actually is
something we should exploit in some
meaningful way makes a lot of sense to
use that information now the problem oh
not the problem yet ah see I lost my
train of thought because I wanted to
talk about the problem there's one trick
with all of this since we have a real
electric car it'll be really nice to
make sure a physics model works and as
one thing our electric or has that the
urban dynamometer test doesn't have
which is altitude when I Drive from
squirrel hill to here i go down forbes
hill and i go up and down a few other
Hills like shady Avenue and on the way
back the same thing in rivers those
hills are essentially inducing more
variability into the commute as if
there's more stop and go traffic so they
make all these effects even more extreme
so the interesting as we did is we took
this barometric reporting altimeter GPS
it's a garmin 60csx the nice thing it
has a barometer so it properly reports
altitude much more precisely than gps
gives you so we took that hooked it up
to our little device so that we
time-stamped and recorded latitude
longitude and altitude along with the
actual current and voltage data from my
car now we can see our physics model add
altitude to it thanks to everybody who
worked at charge curve over the summer
and see how the predictions of the
physics model makes for how much power
the motor will consume and produce
compared to the actual car and that's
where the good news woods you can't
really see this well it's blue in one
case in red on the other case but the
fact of the matter is it's almost a pic
match and that was exciting now for this
test we actually went on Second Avenue
and confused a lot of policemen by
increasing and decreasing our speed to
20 miles three miles 40 miles 50 miles
an hour and then going on forbes hill in
doing the same thing up in on Forbes
health several times so it large test
pattern of different conditions to see
how the car behaves now that's
interesting because at this point you
have a bunch of tools in your toolbox
you have a real car you've collected
some data with you also have with that
GPS enabled altitude enabled gps the
ability to take any car and collect the
same data and then do the same
prediction of power on that car
now the problem a problem is everything
I've talked about makes the urban
commute special because the urban
commute is noisy and high frequency and
that's good for electric cars electrical
motors really what's coming on is I'm
saying electric motors are just awesome
because unlike the gasoline motor they
love to speed up and slow down and they
love to change direction on the current
they don't have any problem with that so
they're perfect for this but here's the
irony and the conundrum this place that
they're perfect for is a place that
batteries are not so perfect for right
batteries aren't typically designed to
handle large amounts of current back and
forth charge and discharge them and
create lots of cycles that's not really
what they were for in the first place in
the Golden Age right batteries are nice
long term stores of power and they like
to parcel it out now there's several
ways you can try and solve this problem
we've got ourselves a good niche but
it's bad for batteries we can pour a lot
of money in to try and make batteries
better and that's happening people are
trying to do that and that's great and
one day that will succeed but the
batteries that are being produced to
that effort are expensive so the cost of
ownership of that electric car is high
until the batteries someday come down in
price but there's another approach you
could imagine to trying to solve that
problem and I'm not the first to suggest
this this is a well-known in the idea is
well is there an energy store that loves
to reverse direction rapidly that isn't
bothered by cycling yeah capacitors so
what if we use a supercapacitor now it
doesn't store as much energy as a
battery but for what energy it does
store it's great at reversing direction
at storing it temporarily and providing
it back to you in a solid-state way and
not showing wear and tear over time it's
not chemical you don't have the same
heat issues so super capacitor seems to
be very appropriate for that except the
energy sees not as good right and it's
more expensive so dollars per unit
energy is high energy densities poorer
than the nicest batteries we've got so
replacing the batteries wholesale with
the supercapacitors just introduces a
new conundrum now we need to improve
super capacitors what if trying to
improve anything we just take the
supercapacitors we've got the batteries
you've got and say let's use each one
for what its best at and what if we
think about this computationally so
computationally what's the cash to
first level cache what it does is create
some sort of buffer here now now Paul's
laughing because he gets this it creates
a buffer where if we get cash hits it's
really good at returning the information
fast but if you don't get a hit you can
go deal with the battery and so the aha
is fine let's create a first level cash
out of the super cap on top of the
battery this is not the same as saying
let's tie the battery and super cap
together to filter the battery so we're
not just putting them in parallel we're
doing something a little smarter we're
saying we have the power to decide how
to use that cash right we can decide how
big the cash should be and we know from
computing Sciences that in fact
sometimes the cash could be really small
compared to the battery and still gain
you hugely infinitive overall impact
right so maybe that'll work here maybe
it's just a metaphor but we can think
about algorithms to maximize what you
can think of as cache hit rate will the
supercapacitor be empty enough for full
enough for what you need right now in
the urban community ecology and what are
the new demands on the new cat battery
you gave as a result because now the
battery is different right it's behind a
cache that changes everything so the
overall architecture and picture thanks
to greg looks like that says we have
places now that we can manipulate the
system we can stick a super cap in there
we have our motor and our battery but
now we can play with the question of how
we trickle charge between the super cap
in the battery and from the motors point
of view we can play with we're
essentially the current goes from the
motor effectively and what can we take
into account to decide how to deal with
this cash how does how to treat this
cash everything we could take everything
driver behavior to the internet maybe
traffic conditions are not depending on
what's going on maybe the fact that the
upcoming light is red or green is
something we should take into account so
you have suddenly a new degree of
freedom in the control of the car and
that opens up some possibilities now the
right next question is to say okay yeah
but sensitivity analysis does this
actually buy us anything how much of a
game do we get out of this so let me go
back to a picture of a commute from
squirrel hill to actually just from
school to squirrel hill and back so this
is happens to be reversed
it's a different different day different
car no same car same driver different
day and so that's a commute and what I
want to talk you through is a fun what
if scenario one of the first things to
imagine doing is a completely naive
buffer or cash so naive that it barely
talks to the battery what if we have a
buffer a supercapacitor that all we do
with it is whenever we slow down the car
if the supercapacitor happens to have
room on board we charge it first now if
it's full recharge the battery but if
it's empty enough we charge the crisper
capacitor and on the other side of the
equation whenever the light turns green
you start going as soon as you start
moving if the super capacitor has
capacity it has charged use that and
when it's empty go back to the battery
that's it so no trickle charging between
the battery and super kept at all this
is like the level one simplest algorithm
you could imagine right and so we can
ask the question what does that do to
what the battery ceased to the battery
duty and here's what it does we're going
to take a small super capacitor and do
that and just simulate that forward and
this is what the battery sees as a
result now again before after so what's
exciting about this is you're seeing a
huge number of the power demands on the
battery disappear now I need to tell you
how big the battery is and how big the
super capacitor is right so you have a
sense of scale this is a 50 watt hour
super capacitor and a 25 kilowatt hour
battery ok so the super capacitor is
like a five hundredth of the size of the
battery if I did that right and the
statistics get really interesting if you
vary capacitor sizes so you can ask the
question how big does the cash have to
be and if we take the cache size and
very it we get a really nice curve it's
a nice curve because at very small cache
sizes and very small capacitor sizes
we're seeing already a tremendous
improvement in savings on the battery
duty for example at 40 watt hours which
is a capacitor about this big that costs
about a thousand dollars okay at 40 what
are we getting we're getting about
thirty five percent savings of battery
duty so total number of kilowatt-hours
the battery seized in and out is going
down by forty percent and if you look at
idle time
the same story idle time would be the
percentage of time the battery is not
doing anything is just sitting there
biding its time wondering why nobody is
talking to it right that's idle time
idle time is essentially zero for the
commute it's just when I'm stopped and
not doing anything but when you add a
very small capacitor 20 watt hours
already idle time goes forty percent
which is the battery sitting still doing
nothing nearly half the time now
intuitively that sounds like a great
thing right it's a great thing for many
reasons what's the number one cost of
ownership issue for electric cars the
battery it's the fact the battery
doesn't last very long this feels like
it might make the battery last longer
simply because it's doing less work yes
but there's a more important reason than
that to thermal issues you're letting
your battery alone and letting it
regulating even out in terms of thermal
situations this is a chemical process
right the batteries chemical giving it
time is great and giving it time to
recover from everything all the load
that you're putting it under is
fantastic you're also putting it under
slightly less load so when you look at
this picture you'll see that there's a
lot more peaks here and that you can
imagine as you increase the capacitor
size the amount of time that that
battery is being loaded down decreases
significantly and the amount of level to
which it's getting loaded down reduces
even if Utley so let me go to the
project now that was all the preliminary
stuff that got us excited right it got
us excited about the opportunity that
may exist to cleverly manipulate energy
between the super capacitor in the
battery in a car in such a way that you
increase the overall efficiency of the
car right and decrease the duty on the
battery and maybe change the thermal
dynamics on the battery in such a way
that the batteries last a lot longer at
the same time all of these parameters
that were manipulating our parameters
that depend on the individual ecology of
a commute so at the same time you want
to make a car that's customizable so in
a way we're saying one-size-fits-all is
out instead of one size fits all let's
customize the car to the commuter to the
terrain that they have to the way they
drive the traffic conditions that they
face on their commute in their times a
day and if we can do that
algorithmically then maybe we've
customized something that's very very
efficient at the same time so that
becomes sort of dream of the charge card
project going forward now there's four
research strands that I want to share
with you today and I get to actually
so I'm going to make announcements which
is always fun so the first announcement
is we care deeply in the creative about
community right what role can
communities of practice have in the
development of new technological
artifacts well in this case is really
easy I've keep telling you that the
individual community ecology matters
well if so then we need to do a few
things one is collect individual
community ecology right we need to do
the best job we can at getting as much
commute information across the US as
possible but secondly we can't just
collect it personal informatics is a big
topic today it's really interesting to
people to be able to measure everything
from Fitbit to BodyMedia to home energy
usage so let's do that for cars why
don't we collect commute data
individuals in such a way that they can
then view their own commute data and
visualize what would happen to the
commute data if they were driving an
electric car what's more this is eco
visualization right because I can do the
what-if for you I could present you with
the opportunity to upload your commute
data see what your commute would be like
an electric clock and see the difference
in place between an electric car version
of your commute and a gasoline car
visionary commute essentially I can
demonstrate your carbon footprint
differential to you nothing excites
people more than navel gazing and being
able to visualize their own future so we
can do both of those in one fell swoop
which is great so that's the National
warehouse of commute data and what's
kind of fun to announce right now is
it's open for business as of right now
so there's a website you can go to after
this meeting called charge card orgy and
that's what the website looks like and
so here's the deal with this website one
of the things you can do on this website
is you can do go to say electrify my
commute and it'll hand hold you if you
need hand-holding but i don't i can say
start thing as soon as i say that i'm
going to go to a screen where i can put
in my name of course i can do an alias
if I like for privacy I can put in what
kind of car I was driving so maybe I was
driving I don't drive compact car let's
say I don't know what would I Drive I
would drive a Honda something cord there
or I could go in and manually enter my
car specifics because maybe I have a
heavy car because it's a bag of sand in
the back I can enter the outside
temperature the roots
the traffic types all the information
about the community ecology that makes
my commute special and interesting and
then I upload GPS data click on that
button because I have a GPS in my car
and I've recorded the GPX file from the
GPS which is essentially a series of
latitude and longitude points on my
commute now what happens is when you
upload that to us right away we take all
the data now the things get fun we care
about altitude right and GPS altitude is
nowhere near good enough we've done this
in sative analysis it doesn't give us
the altitude measurements such that we
could really figure out power in the
time so USGS was happy enough to give us
about two weeks ago all altitude data
for the entire US so now we have that
mirrored here at the CMU so you have
that on a server large describe so when
you give us your data we take all the
data we apply to it all the altitude
readings from the USGS that are accurate
and we provide right back to you on this
interface what your power profile would
look like in an electric car in a car
that has your weight and has as many
passengers as you had that day and what
the price differential is like so that
becomes essentially personal informatics
meets equal visualization we're
visualizing where we could be and we're
seeing our own informatics let's look at
some examples I'll go back to data here
which shows national data as we accrue
it we've primed the pump with a few
locations but we obviously need your
friends to add where will I go let's go
to Texas for a second here Texas 31
miles in Austin I know who that is let's
go look at this so first of all trip
stats this is a 30 mile commute it took
two hours and 13 minutes yeah that's
urban driving definitely not rural
driving net elevation change is almost
nil and look at that average speed 60
miles an hour even though he went 70 at
one point actually she in this case so I
can go and look at the data as uploaded
speed over time for example that's what
the commute looked like in speed so in
the speed world that's for commute fine
now we can take that and if you lies
what it would be for that very commute
if it were an electric car is the
electric car commute
and you'll be relieved and excited to
see we have some significant excursions
up from the axis from the zonta Laxus
which are regeneration opportunities
right places that we can exploit
regeneration now let's go look at the
stats overall and see what's going on
and this is where it gets fun we've seen
the trip stats as soon as you upload the
data though we can give you electric car
stats we can see that if this is where
an electric car it consumed a total of
eight kilowatt hours of power that's
interesting to know right it kilowatt
hours of power that's about how much you
have an as n car that's a neat kilowatt
hour battery pack so it gives you a
sense of how much power you got
percentage of power regeneration thirty
percent in flat Austin so that's even
without altitude changes and now the fun
part what if we had a super cab we can
forward compute all that so if you had a
super cap running our really silly
algorithm right the naive first order
buffer we'd have forty percent savings
of battery duty with algorithm alone and
if you look at the heat models that
we've implemented thanks to Jay
Whitaker's group here the heat saving is
about thirty five percent which is to
say the peak battery temperature goes
from 96 degrees Fahrenheit 140 degrees
Fahrenheit to 96 degrees Fahrenheit now
this matters peak temperatures matter
because it again that is a chemical
process and the fact that we're dropping
that means that we're not going to have
nearly the same kind of break down
chemically as you would otherwise have
so that's an example of the kind of
visualization that you can create really
quickly drive crosses of fun 12 and you
can imagine what car was it honda accord
2006 anybody know how many miles per
gallon gets 27 in the city 20 okay i'm
not going to buy 27c let's say two
dollars and ninety cents and let's say
eleven cents a kilowatt is that ok j all
right fine
this is a real-time pricing so with the
car I'll just read it to you right with
the car the trip is four dollars and
sixty cents with an electric car it's
ninety cents so it's about an eighty-one
percent savings in immediate price of
course that's not accounting for the
purchase of the car and all the you know
money that you put into the system of
course it's also not accounting for the
mechanic that you're going to pay to
keep fixing the gasoline car whilst the
electric doesn't need the mechanic so it
doesn't he come / a new that doesn't
Nene mechanic was a bit strong we go
back to that so that's one view of what
we can provide and oh my did it go all
the way to the beginning there and
what's exciting about that whole
direction of inquiry is maybe we can
cause people to have a sense of
conversation about the what-if about
what my committee is like and how it
compares to my neighbors commute and
what the energetics of my commute are
compared to my neighbors commute and
that I believe is an exciting thing to
do for the public especially as electric
cars come on the market now we have a
second problem second problem that we
can also look at in a community-based
way is the control algorithm remember we
have super cat battery electric vehicle
now and we have a whole control
algorithm question here how do you
manage the energy when do you decide to
charge and discharge at super cap oh
this person is coming along just like
they did yesterday and they always stop
there two out of three times they stop
there I'm going to discharge the
capacitor so it's ready to accept the
charge and still slow the car down or
I'm sitting at a red light I have
nowhere to go but faster so let's charge
the capacitor up gradually so we can
discharge it on the green and take off
and not use the battery at all so in all
of those key situations we're talking
about intelligent control and boy that's
a great place for hackers to think
especially since we want to be able to
invent new ways to take advantage of
everything the Internet can offer to
hack that everything from traffic models
that may be on the internet for that
particular Road system to weather
patterns and weather forecasts so we've
been thinking how to do this now we're
going to i'm sure graduates and master's
degrees and maybe even a PhD on this
question of intelligent control of the
car but we'd open this up broadly so the
second thing we're doing which is a
little bit unusual especially for me the
anti contest guy is we're doing invent a
control algorithm
so we've taken the entire program that
predicts power consumption and manages
the supercapacitor and we made it all
open source it's all available in Ruby
on Rails and what we're going to
announce which is kind of fun is anybody
can download this now but we're going to
announce a contest in which anybody can
try and create a better program a better
way of managing this and there's an
optimal we're looking for which is
minimize the current squared on the
battery over time that's the thing that
we're interested in because that means
thermal characteristics go down and
batteries last as long as humanly
possible so that's the challenge now we
want to have a contest we haven't worked
out all the details yet but I will have
to share this with you there is one
major issue with the contest you have to
have a prize and everybody I've talked
to keeps telling me that the same price
that we need unfortunately which is it
has to be electric car so I get it we'll
do it we have to work out the details
find a sponsor and all that once you've
got that nailed will announce the
contest and we'll open it up and then
whoever wins will get an electric car so
there you are that's that contest where
am I will it be use super capacitor
battery electric oh that's a good
question speaking of which we need to
build one the third research strand of
charge car is the numbers we're seeing
are very promising and as we collect
national commute data it'll be exciting
to see where that's headed and by the
way we're priming the pump we have five
gps's that we've already started on
we're sending them to our friends and
family around the country to just start
priming this pump and collecting as much
and we also need ten boards that hack
the rav4 EV and collect data directly
from the robbery and we're starting a
lending program i'm going to send those
out to the two let's still drive the
route for you so there's some organic
spread but also we're actually pushing
to get some of the people out to us data
but once we get all this data right
we'll be able to really run the
algorithms and understand whether
there's a significant difference that
can be had by these kinds of
architectural considerations but nothing
beats having a real car we have to have
a car on which we can actually mess with
the supercapacitor right actually
actually play with it well play with the
algorithms on a real car and measure
everything there is to measure and try
different community college
right here in Pittsburgh so we started
on that thanks to everybody else in the
charge car team notably Greg podner
who's here and ben Brown and Josh
Shapiro have all been deeply involved in
that process and so I have some pictures
to show you and it's actually nice out
so we're going to go look at the car
afterwards for anybody who's interested
we chose the Toyota Scion because
aesthetically it's the most beautiful
car on the market today because it's
boxy so it's got lots of quarters to fit
round and rectangular batteries I mean
rectangular and square batteries in i'll
just give you a little picture show this
is a basement of nipple simon hall after
we found it a mechanic a chop shop
mechanic who was willing to take all of
the gasoline press out of the car for
free because they're worth more to him
than his time taking about which is
already kind of a nice result so he took
them all out and he's interested in
doing this again by the way so he's on
team now and then we proceeded to put
things in the car so for electric
motorcycle electric motors to for the
right wheel front to for the left front
wheel all on a giant motor mount that
fits right in the car and there they are
installed in the car there's things in a
car that are controlled by essentially
the sickle to the motion of the motor
right the pulleys things like this power
steering pump and a motor booster the
brake booster and so for all those who
have to put intellect versions of those
and then the fun pictures all those the
cables the car we built is low voltage
it's a 48 volt electric car and there's
a reason for that because we don't want
to die and because we only have so much
budget and a supercapacitor that's 50
watt hours and 48 volts is this big in
seventeen hundred dollars if I built
your standing electric cars that's a 400
volt car I'd need sixteen thousand
dollars for supercapacitors it's just
too much money so low voltage car
affords us the sensibility of actually
playing with the super capacitor and the
battery without without actually running
out of money but that means the cables
are huge so we have extremely large you
know I don't know triple not quadruple
not cables in there and then the
controller in the back a homebrew
controller to begin with but that's nice
because we can access everything sensor
the whole thing out the censor board
that the create lab created that
measures the temp
currents voltages all across the system
so that we've completely sensorized the
car and now the fun part the insides so
any good robot has to have an emergency
stop this has two one for the super
capital one for the battery large double
throw switches that you turn the car off
with as soon as you realize something is
horribly wrong and then a regen stick
just like 1988 we had in our car and
that makes a lot of sense because now we
can start to dizzer regen we can play
with regen and maximize it and see what
happens when you really play with it and
try and get the very largest amount of
regen you can out of the car also by
putting the region on your hand we can
not touch the brake pedal so in a safety
sense we haven't dealt any blows to the
overall performance and system break
except of course that we have an
electric booster now last but not least
in board computer on which we can hack
all sorts of algorithms to control the
super capacitor battery energetics and
have a display device so that we can
manipulate those controls so that kind
of is the car the scion be charged car
car the very first car we've tried to
manipulate and I'm very pleased to
report it was driven under its own power
up to the gates high bay so what's
waiting for us there now the last fourth
final research strand that we have as
part of charge car again community
robotics lab is all about community and
we keep asking which communities of
practice matter here I've already talked
about a couple one is the hacker
community they could really help us in a
distributed way with algorithms and I
think they'd love it second I've talked
about the chameleon community they can
really help us with data that can do
equal visualization but they can also
provide the informatics that really
allows us to understand what the impact
this can have economically and
energetically on the country but there's
another community that's really perfect
and in fact Pittsburgh's the perfect
place for it what do we have in
Pittsburgh we have this incredible
capability in machining and working with
our hands right you have awesome
mechanics you have a ton of chop shops
and you have incredible machine shops
right and you have universities these
two fantastic universities so you have
this very high tech understanding and
Concepcion at the same time you have
people's
actually handle material create product
and so combining those in this case is
really interesting because the third
community of practice is mechanics what
if we could find mechanics in Pittsburgh
who are interested engage them pay for
their time so that they really are
interested it can afford to be
interested right and then work with them
to create recipes for converting cars in
Pittsburgh to super cat battery electric
vehicles if we can come up with the
right pieces for that recipe and
subsidize those pieces if we can machine
the right parts that are hard to machine
and allow ourselves to prepare them and
offer them up to the mechanics so the
mechanics have the key pieces in hand
and know the types of cars these work on
and we have the algorithms worked out
with exciting to have Pittsburgh be a
Center where you can bring your car
hopefully not your only car and have to
pull the engine out pull the gas tank
out pull the transmission out put in the
supercapacitor in the battery and now
you can drive away silently and that's
really interesting because we actually
think there's an interest here the one
chop shop guy we talked to that pulled
the engine out totally interested this
idea working with us of continuing to
have a part and I think that will find
that repeatedly the case in fact every
mechanic I've talked to about the car
just driving around my electric car has
been totally excited about electric cars
in fact every blue-collar person you
talked to is totally excited by develop
your eyes so that's the last bit it's
kind of an economic development gambit
that says maybe we can build regional
capacity since we know this is working
so well and create that the real dream
by the way is maybe we can get everybody
who has ladies cars to have the same
sticker on the side that says something
no charge card SB EV and one day you
know you're going to keep a hot and
drinking coffee and you're just watching
as once every five minutes and sve
drives by and this would be the only
city in the world would that have the
first one where it happens I just think
that'd be totally cool ok last thanks
the charge card team is a large number
of people who volunteered their time to
this project and J Whittaker and J apt
have both provided tremendous advice to
us and Donna August and David Hayes were
both here provided all the funding for
this project so thank you to everybody
making his possible
now we've set up two cars in the gates
high bay downstairs on the bottom most
floor that way nope that way and there
the rav4 EV and the Scion xB and they're
both operable so they both work so if
you're interested in seeing the car is
live after we take a couple of questions
here that's okay we'll wander down there
and let you play and maybe my team can
go ahead and go down there so that
whoever wants to just go down there can
go and start playing with cars so I was
wrong twice that that's a good question
we haven't looked into the legality of
conversions when you have to get
licensing this car happens to have a
current registration right now I don't
know what we're going to do when we have
to pass the emissions test next year
I've actually gone through that problem
with my electric vehicle so my my raw
for is still licensed in California and
the reason for that is every every
emissions test drive went to here said
you have to have a tailpipe to put the
sensor on and I kept explaining there is
no tailpipe on the car and he said
there's no option on the computer for
that you have to have a tailpipe and at
one point I told him just just hanging
on the bumper so he hung it on the
bumper and he came back and said it says
fraud because it's not measuring any
particle matter yes but at some point
one has to deal with that of course yeah
yes efficient if you can get the
manufacturers to supply a part of the
year gasoline guts in high society we
must pass for Easter yes and in fact
we've just started talking about the
idea of trying to take one of the
existing electric cars now remember even
a year ago it was harder to imagine
getting hold of electric car and so now
as I seeing this wave front catch I
think it's a great opportunity for us to
start to partner with them get their
cars and use their cars yet although I
want local discards because otherwise
it's a ridiculous number of super
capacitors so that's a little bit of
challenge although the Zeb for instance
is 72
just great work bless Danny I'm
wondering actually I think first of all
I think you're allowed to build your own
hit car so once you can a license
somehow but I know quietly scalable I'm
also wondering that a diss idea of
inviting hacking inviting sort of
participation mothers obviously going to
pay off you know many asleep and one of
his also an incentive for kind of having
up you know hacked by kind of education
models I do you think about and we
here's a device that not so long ago was
sort of designed to appeal to everyone
complete are you but no one really
deeply and sort of you have this app
store could there be kind of the app
store model for you know look I'm late
for meeting they go on a little slightly
different profile level to change the
battery characteristics that might
actually want violate raw loss eat a
little bit i don't know they defined
with that idea a little bit citrusy
there's something about this I didn't
say you know there was a study a while
ago on pollution in the house and it was
a really excellent study because it
should you can put pollution years in
people's homes and show them that they
have five times more pollution than the
federal standards and it doesn't change
their behavior at all they go so what
but then you put a pollution meter in
their home and then you you tell them
that their pollution in the house is
twice worse than their neighbors and
they do everything to change so you know
once you have that computer and once you
have networking and once you're actually
recording although this commute data
right you can actually show how
efficient Eric drives compared to me you
know how many cents per mile do you
drive how many kilowatts do you waste
and how fast you go you know I go even
faster than you and I use list of us
take back right so there's an amazing
opportunity for a kind of competition
between people the hacked by mentality i
think is absolutely fantastic there too
and that's very exciting I mean that's a
whole possible feature that I think
would be really fun to go to so Mel and
then so you don't one little tiny fear
when you said that unlike batteries that
super capacitors don't have any
chemistry and therefore don't have
battery problems they are electrolytic
capacitors most people describe them as
something between a battery in the
capacitor what are the light conditions
there or have they been used under the
circumstances long enough to know the
answers so they know these is a decent
of course but the standard things that
you see published about the super
capacitors that we're using Maxwell are
million or more cycles with eighty
percent of the original energy
energetics kind of frequency spectrum
that I don't know yet that makes me seem
mad let's see so if you're reducing the
vamp of the battery I guess if I'm
there's an opportunity there between the
smaller battery and I am wondering
look at Jenny news because the battery
or the man because he had less way yeah
there's two issues that this is the
first of all a lot of these cars have
huge batteries because they're trying to
do a one for a replacement the gas car
so they have 2,000 pounds of batteries
so that the car has 250 miles range
which isn't where we're headed but it's
not just that I'm if you take a Prius
right the battery is only discharged to
something like forty percent of its
original total charge level in other
words they're over specking the battery
to have Headroom so they're only using a
small part of it so it lasts longer
because we deep discharge the batteries
they do worse so yes if we're playing
with the batteries right perhaps we can
actually lose the head have a smaller
battery on board and the logistical tail
from that is the car slider so you get
more range it's kind of like the
standard regiment for Space Flight boy
18 nothing like it's really important
because we need less fuel and oh yeah
the fuel weighs a lot so in that sense
it's really important there's a second
more subtle issue here though we're
changing the demand on the battery the
demand dynamics if you do this right
what's the battery see a little usage
little you sir will you surgeon to get
your destination so suddenly the level
with which you need to use exotic
chemistry's and parts in your batteries
so that you have really really high
currents and they can handle incredible
thermal changes goes away so in fact the
real dream is you don't just do this
these designer batteries you make
batteries that are actually not better
than today's batteries but cheaper than
today's batteries for this particular
niche and I think that's a really
exciting place for future development
too yes
possibilities of charging the car
inductively as you driving along the
highway extending its range so you're
not charging needs to be really close
and if you go downstairs you'll see
actually an inductive pedal charger on
my car so I have inductive charging but
as the as the distance increases it gets
much much less efficient and so on a
highway that would be tough people used
to talk about buses and every bus stop
this inductive charger so you pull up in
a Christian but I don't know it's tough
it's a challenge of a massive
engineering challenge to put that kind
of thing off you'd have to get a huge
amount of energy under the road right
there maybe that's another big super
capacitor why I'm in front of God but
where do you live up on the gas
components and put in an entry like
today but it's in the person that you
did with you got into it when you got
out we expect something that's the case
you can have one way to start this
industry is instantly and the equivalent
of the clunkers program I get in your
own cars with Ibaka gas engine as it
doesn't mean as that's what mechanics
industry would be good for and it's the
ultimate recycling meets high-tech your
recycling the old car you're using a lot
of the parts over again and you're
putting the highest of high tech back in
that car to make it to be commuted
vehicle that I think that's exciting
getting today's car manufacturers to
sell you what we call gliders a car
that's missing the gas engine altogether
many have tried to do that and have had
a lot of trouble Tesla's sort of
succeeded with lotus is it fiat Lotus
but I mean it took them years to try and
get a company to be even willing to
consider to comprehend selling a car off
the assembly line without some of the
parts in it I think the recycling pitch
is really fantastic Mike
so where do you want to finish this and
then do a very real world test to tell
you the real answer but the only unreal
answer I can give you is the internal
resistance is really low on these super
capacitors typically so we expect it to
be only better than a batteries charge
discharge profile but I'm curious to
test that it'll be great to test it with
the car because we can charge the super
cat run around and measure total range
and then put the same number of hemp
hours into the battery to the exact same
thing does anybody know we don't know
yet we really don't know yet and the
problem is it depends on the particular
context in which you're doing it right
even if I read the paper that says in a
laboratory experiment at a certain
current it was a lot better I want to
know what it's what it's like on the
ground in a real car commuting but I'm
hopeful that it'll be it's on there
probably under some years ago when
electric vehicles were around
in this wondering if we found the
electric pass under years ago so 19 of
war within the last production electric
vehicle and I have somewhere at home an
ad for it and it's fabulous it's an
electric car that goes it's something
really i think eight or ten miles now
imagine you know to a culture used to
walking and taking a horse that's not
bad that's that takes you in a rural
setting to town and back maybe when i
drive my car it's quiet okay the air is
less filthy and you're essentially
isolating the pollution creation to
specific places where if you're lucky
you can leverage and decrease pollution
and that's not even talking about solar
power and whatnot so what i imagine our
world would be like is we'd have a lot
less noise pollution you know I lived in
bernal heights in San Francisco at the
crossroads of two highways and we were
never able to whisper to each other
truly and people grow up and die in
places like that and that noise
pollution has to have effect on our on
our being the same time the air
pollution is a massive problem in places
like Pittsburgh and it's not just us
it's everybody upstream with us and I
have to believe that they would have
changed the way we think about dealing
with pollution having it isolated to
specific places I think makes it much
easier to think about legislation than
having it spread out in a very
disseminated way